so I know you've produced numerous
movies you've worked for other people
but you wanted to direct for a very long
time and I was wondering what that
journey was like and now to finally be
able to direct at least three movies now
more it sounds like yeah on the horizon
as well well I did two movies prior to
passion flicks I directed two movies
prior to passion flex what three movies
actually I started out as an actor and
then I went into directing and after
directing my first feature I realized
it's really really hard to actually get
it out and do things and then I went
into producing and then I produced for
the next 10 years and it was after I had
my kids that I realized I wanted to do
something that's more creatively
fulfilling for me and I went and met
with an executive producer who I had
produced a couple of movies for before
and she is an awesome woman she works at
lifetime now her name's Sharon Boras and
I said to her she said what do you want
to do and I said well actually I want to
direct and she goes mm-hmm okay I'll let
you direct I'll give a movie now you
want to direct it I mean yeah sure okay
and within a month I was in prep on that
movie and directed and that was called
you cast a spell on me and that's the
one that Joni saw so it all sort of
having that lunch with her basically
changed my life and brought us to
passion flicks because I she said I
could direct that movie I directed it
Joni sword she loved it Joni contacted
me and now we have passion flicks that's
basically that's the short story so I
got to make two movies for Sharon I made
that one and then the following year
they hired me to make a Christmas a
Cinderella Christmas which was a
Christmas story also a love story for
ion as well great experience that's
where I met Emma Rigby and then as soon
as we made passion flicks I asked Emma
Rigby to be the first female lead of
passion flicks for Hollywood dirt so it
all just sort of worked together I was
very fortunate of course it was you know
15 years of slugging
to get to that point but I was very
fortunate to be given the opportunity by
a great supporter of woman so to know
that somebody believed in you that
quickly where you were probably just
coming thinking maybe down the line
there was something probably weren't
expecting it so fast
what was that first day on set like
terrifying empowering both um it was it
was exciting actually
I felt I definitely felt that I was in
my own and I owned it for sure it was a
very positive experience that entire
movie was wonderful again the two lead
actors that I work with Brian McPartlin
and Nicki deloach had great chemistry we
had great chemistry together and so we
we store our in contact and we still
want to make another movie together so
it was a really positive experience I
knew exactly what I wanted as a
filmmaker I had a great DP with me
and so he so he was very knowledgeable
not you know a lot of experience Oh
actually on that one on that one I did I
had it but I had a great I had a great
DP she was new to the new to the field
in that particular one but she was so
supportive so I had the DP that had a
lot of experience in the next movie on
Cinderella Christmas but anyway so but
it was a it was a positive experience I
mean everything was it was just fun and
I think once you are doing something
that you are passionate about and that
you really truly believe you should be
doing you do a great job and you excel
in that and so that's why to me it's not
considered work it's considered play so
I can do it forever
which is great have a great time so
going back to that first sort of
experience it was also the chemistry in
the environment it worked it all seemed
to kind of work yeah the chemistry in
the environment I mean I think at the
end of the day and I yeah fortunately
have been told this by a lot of my crew
members is that the environment is
created by the director so the directors
basically the mood on set is going to be
based on how the director is feeling
that day and if I was throwing tantrums
and yeah
yelling at everybody probably wouldn't
have had a been a it wouldn't have been
a great set to work on but you know I
arrived and we were laughing and joking
and having a fun time from the second we
started and so everybody was laughing
and joking and having a great time and
that really helped
we actually my producer Gina who's the
producer and all the movies as well
she she and I have a no policy
we actually give people a warning so
when we hire them we say hi listen the
only drama that happens on the set is
going to be on screen so if you're gonna
be dramatic in any way and cause
problems you are welcome to leave you
don't have to stay nobody is making you
work here if you don't like it you are
absolutely welcome to leave but if you
do like it we'd love for you to stay and
let's have a great time we're gonna go
and make them a B and it's not rocket
science and it's not brain surgery and
people's lives aren't on the line here
so let's just go and have fun time
creating something and so that goes over
really well with a lot of crew members
and if there there have been a few times
when we've had some crew members that
have been and actors people that have
not been nice and so we kindly invite
them to leave so having that sense of
humor yeah yeah well I would hope so but
yeah it happens it definitely does it
just sometimes just people clash
whatever I think sometimes to having a
sense of humor sometimes I don't know we
see that in people yeah and even if it's
just going to the grocery store you know
it's rare and maybe just because la is
so crowded and everybody's thinking of
being somewhere else doing something
else but just having that sense of humor
and maybe people just feel like okay I
can relax a little bit yeah I'm very
funny on set apparently I I love
laughter I mean romantic comedies are my
strength so it's really important that's
what I love to make the most so
Hollywood dirt was definitely a great
one for me it's an empowering woman but
it's a comedy and it's a romance and
then matchmakers playbook also a comedy
what was actually hard for me was after
burn after shock because it's a drama
so I had
to try and you know you know figure out
how to make a drama more than and still
keep it light and funny on set because
there's so much dramatic so many
dramatic scenes in that movie but if you
see the behind the scenes as soon as I
call cut everyone's laughing and having
a great time I whistle a lot so people
you know I whistle and I sing on set a
lot which is somewhat embarrassing
because I don't realize that I'm doing
it until the boom operator or the sound
mixer will come up and just start
recording it and then they'll play it
back and I think oh wow yes that's me
whistling on set but it's it keeps it
there's a levity then to set so it just
keeps everything light and fun and and I
think that's important but romantic
comedy is definitely my strength I say
although I did like making after Bernard
Jacques
you